why is having limited resources a bad
excuse for not making a film
I think anything you want to do in film
you get you there's no such thing as
unlimited resources really right so you
have to decide what are the confines of
what I'm doing and if you if you have
100 million dollars there are confines
if you have you know one dollar there
are confines and uh having that those
limitations and those constraints is an
opportunity in my view it's not it's not
a a pain or a punishment or anything
like that it's an opportunity to say
what can I do creatively or what can I
do in a smart way that works within
those constraints and that's why you
know when we're
um
when we're thinking about what film
we're going to make I might have a
script that's 100 million dollar script
not going to make that film not going to
try to make that film but I know that if
I you know if I have these resources I'm
going to write something that works
within the confines of those resources
it helps me to be creative because it
says
instead of having the whole world to
write about instead of saying there are
unlimited ideas I know I only have this
much stuff to work with and we we write
a lot for location so you know for
example
um Sophia my creative and life Partners
parents had a barn with sheep in it and
so we're like you know it would be
really interesting if we if we uh use
this as part of telling this this type
of story that we want to tell and that
gives us some you know production value
for no no cost and and uh but you know
we wouldn't have necessarily done that
if I had the world to work with I
wouldn't have said oh you know this
sheep Barn is a really interesting you
know thing to write into the story so
you start to actually use the pieces and
the resources that you have and it helps
you it actually helps you creatively to
to
um to do something that I think you know
is more connected and meaningful and you
value the things that you have more than
if you have you know kind of unlimited
options
and then going back to what we talked
about a little bit earlier in that a lot
of people say well I don't want to do
this unless this is the budget
um
why do you think some people don't want
to utilize what they have again is that
fear yeah I think it's fear I mean I
think the only excuse is really fear and
um
we also take the approach we're very DIY
in general so we coming from music we
basically were like well we gotta you
know we taught ourselves to play our
instruments right so that's the starting
point for it we're like we'll learn how
to play songs on our own we'll learn how
to write songs on our own then we'll
learn how to record on our own you know
maybe we went to a studio first but then
we realized that's expensive so let's
let's learn how to do that so when we
enter film we sort of think like well we
better learn you know how to how to
shoot we better learn how to edit we
better learn how to do sound and uh I
think a lot of people are afraid to sit
down and dedicate the time to learning
those things so if you're not willing to
do that it can be harder if you don't
you know if you don't have money again
any problem can be solved with money uh
or you have to find some kind of other
you know Creative Solutions so if you
don't have money you need to actually
sit down dedicate the time the energy to
basically learning everything you need
to learn you need to make the social
networks and the kind of uh creative
networks to get people to come together
and to to work with you to create
something and it's intimidating it's an
intimidating task if you're not used to
it that's that's to sit down and say
like I'm going to learn to be a
filmmaker
um it's gotten easier in the in recent
years because now people have phones and
they can it's really easy I mean it may
not be
you know a blockbuster Masterpiece but
you can make a movie on your phone
you know reasonable looking movie better
than you know what digital looked like
10 years ago and on the best cameras 15
years ago maybe
um
but uh I think people have just a fear
of that or a feeling of in being
intimidated by the the process because
it's such a big process
in film is there no right way to do
anything like is there are there certain
things that you must do you know whether
it's Dogma 95 and these certain rules
that have to happen I don't I don't
think there's really a right way to do
anything in the broad sense I think
there's a right way to accomplish if you
set a specific goal or you set a
specific Target there's probably a right
way to accomplish that Target
so uh if my goal is to have my film play
at a certain festival or to to reach a
certain audience there are ways that are
going to work for accomplishing that
goal and there are ways that are not
going to work and so you have to think
about what you're what what is it that
you're intending to do when you make a
film when you set out to make a film
what is the purpose of that film who is
the film for what do you want to happen
with the film once it's done
um and then I think you need to make
decisions about what is you know the
quote unquote right right set of things
to do in order to achieve those goals
did the two of you encounter that when
you were first starting out with film
for sort of transitioning for music did
for people like oh well then you have to
do a b and c or else it's not worth it
yeah when we were first doing uh our
first we're making our first feature
film and we were trying to hire uh a
crew or hire camera people and so on
um some of them are like wow you have to
shoot it this way you have to do this or
you have to approach that and we're
thinking like well we can't afford it's
not going to happen we can't afford to
do that and so you know we kind of just
push those people aside and kept kind of
looking for the people who are willing
to find the solution uh to make it the
way that you know it was viable and I
think you know what what ended up
happening in a lot of cases is those
people who
um kind of had those strict rules about
how how it must be done haven't really
made movies uh they're you know 10 years
down the line haven't really made a
movie haven't really accomplished much
of anything some of them have uh you
know responded maybe with some jealousy
toward us or some some negativity toward
us about you know the success of some of
this and I understand their point of
view now like a little bit because you
know at this stage I wouldn't
necessarily work on a movie like if you
if you said to me do you want to come
work on this movie we're going to shoot
it on my phone and we're gonna you know
record it with audio on the phone and do
that do all the stuff I might say no to
that because it's not really but I
wouldn't say that the person is wrong I
just say that's not the right project
for for me to be involved with and
understanding that uh I can understand
the different perspectives but I do
think most people when they're trying to
set up rules those rules harm them more
than they help them but it also feels
like if the whole thing goes badly it's
my fault sort of I don't think there's
anyone else to blame the blame is always
going to follow my shoulders that's a
quote we found okay
talk about blame and creating being uh
you know in charge of in charge of a
project I mean ultimately right the buck
the buck stops at the uh at the director
of the producer or the team that's kind
of at the top
um yeah but I think you know you can't
be afraid
you can't be afraid of disaster
because
disasters I mean I guess it could happen
instantaneously but typically the
process of making a film things are
always going wrong and it's a matter of
how you tackle those problems as they
arise so even what feels like a disaster
in one moment you can find a solution
you can make adjustments you can keep
moving forward and uh you know if you're
cut out to be a filmmaker you'll find a
way to get to an end point where
everybody it may not be the film that
you know you're thrilled about or that
you're most happy about but where
everybody feels like okay we did our
best with what we had we got to where we
we could with it
um and I think people understand that
even when it's not perfect
they know if they if they see that
process and they see that dedication
they know that the people who are kind
of in charge of the thing
put their best effort forward and uh I
don't think you can feel guilty about
putting your best effort forward even if
it's not ultimately what you had hoped
for
you've mentioned that both you and
Sophia have committed to learning every
job on set
play The Devil's Advocate for a moment
would that make it more you know sort of
the the Jack of all trades master of
none how do you how do you reconcile
that yeah I think to some degree that
that's going to be true but
um
the way I view it is
I need to get good enough on set
at every job that I my goal is to hire
somebody better than me ultimately to
replace me right I don't want to do all
those jobs I I want to replace them find
somebody uh who's better than me to
replace me for that but in a pinch if I
need to do something I'm going to be
able to solve those problems and luckily
for us I mean the thing is we come
because we come from music we did audio
for so many years in in different
regards we did uh sound recording we did
you know music production we did mixing
and all that so it was very easy to jump
into production sound recording and
sound mixing uh but post mixing and
everything
um and then we mostly dedicated our
interest to understanding cameras the
technical and creative parts of
cinematography and camera work
um
and anything else on set we just need to
be able to to fill in gaps is kind of
how I see it uh so
I don't think you need to be a master on
an independent film is anybody probably
uh uh you know full professional Master
at any of the jobs they're doing
maybe you know I mean it depends on how
you define that their people are very
good I mean we work with excellent
people I'm not I'm not saying that we
don't
um
but you know you're balancing all the
different things and and ultimately the
way I view it is
when I set out to make the film my job
is to make sure the film gets made and
so if I have to do an imperfect job of
something along the way there
that's what has to be done in order for
the film to get made
and to your point about hiring people if
you don't know what you were sort of in
undertaking it would be difficult to
know what's this person's skill level
absolutely yeah yeah so for hiring
absolutely yeah I mean it also helps to
because sometimes it's a challenge
because I need to hire somebody like for
post-production for example if I'm gonna
have an editor on the film or I'm going
to have a a re-recording mixer on the
phone they have to be better than I am
and I'm not saying I'm great but I'm
better than most people are going to be
in the in the sort of budget range that
we're working with or the in independent
film so
it's rare that that you know we're going
to be able to go out now in our most
recent film we do have an editor for
example
um but
yeah I can then evaluate how good
somebody is at a job I can
um
fill in if I need to and uh it's just
helpful because onset if I'm directing
or producing I know what their job is
like I know what this the sound mixer is
doing and I know if I hear something I'm
I know oh there's going to be a problem
for the sound mixer and I can talk to
the sound mixer and say oh I know
there's this is going on I can be I can
be conscientious about the challenges
that each of the crew members are facing
at that moment and try to work with them
better be a better kind of leader and
manager because if you're trying to be a
leader and you have no idea what anybody
below you is doing uh you're not going
to be a very good leader